so USBC hub for macbook air
Thank You Apple for eliminating all
ports of all kinds so that we have to
buy dongles
[Music]
I'm yeardley Smith you may know me best
dad the voice of Lisa Simpson this is my
Amazon last 10 I bought some adidas
alpha bounce shoes I'm actually not a
sneaker head I kind of I work out I work
out hard and I have one pair of sneakers
these are zero drop that's the thing I
get plantar fasciitis these seem to work
out for me these happen to be what was
that color they're like blush or almond
or something I also got this skin medica
rejuvenating hydrator this was a
recommendation that was given to me when
I was shopping at Sephora one day when I
was out of town shooting a movie from my
production company in Hammond Louisiana
a couple of months ago and I really
liked it it's kind of spendy
and I'm not that girl like I don't
really get spendy skin products but it
quite like this so I use it at night and
I use it under my foundation does it
work I don't know but it does not work
so there's that turmeric curcumin
because my general practitioner told me
that cultures that put a lot of turmeric
in their food don't lose their minds
they don't get dementia I'm all about
that Oh
sign me up and I actually and I like
curry so I'm I'll put it in my food I'll
take it in a capsule I'll just keep
taking it I'll just you know sign me up
load me in I'm
and I'll turn to poo yellow okay so I
bought ten oral-b replacement toothbrush
heads from my electric toothbrush
because I actually have a slight
obsession with oral hygiene i floss all
the time when I go out like when I'm on
the red carpet here's a little secret
about me I actually have a little mini
dental floss in my evening bag I floss
all the time and I brush my teeth like
crazy so I changed my toothbrush once a
month I'm kind of a nut so yeah I needed
ten of those
so USBC hub for macbook air Thank You
Apple for eliminating all ports of all
kinds so that we have to buy dongles
and all kinds of extra things for
everything at the same time I really
love my MacBook Air I know I get it you
have me over a barrel fine the expo dry
erase marker in red because I have gym
in my house and we my trainer writes the
unbearable workout on the mirror in red
dry erase marker jerk
[Music]
electrolyte concentrate newsflash this
one it's unsweetened it tastes if you
put too much in it's kind of sour
nothing is better for a hangover if that
ever happens to you never happens to me
or if you find yourself just generally
dehydrated just add it to your water and
it's better than Gatorade because it has
no sugar or additives organic barley
grass powder again my trainer said
you're going you need this it will cure
what ails you I'm not even sure what
that is
what ails me but I'm like okay sign me
up so I put it in my smoothie which I
call the black beauty so basically it's
water
it's wild blueberries a little bit of
ice this barley grass powder so I'm
spirulina and that's it it's delish and
it's black I'm not even kidding it's
yeah it's it's for real here we are
again with my obsession with oral
hygiene 8 Pro enamel tubes of toothpaste
I do have a sense of teeth probably
because I brush them so much and I do
like the fresh breath fresh flavor this
is good and again with the dental floss
though there you go and I like the glide
because slides right between the cake
you know it's real easy and it's sort of
taste these starts there just like us oh
[Music]
you do want to brush your teeth twice a
day because that will catch up with you
in a hot minute when you're older it
will be so much worse